- Energy.
- We have the energy.
- Sustain that sense of energy.
- Great energy.
- Energy.
- Hello Believe Nation, today
we're going to talk about
how you can raise your energy.
And as always if you hear something
that really resonates with you
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well.
Enjoy!
(bright, triumphant orchestral music)
- When I started Microsoft,
I didn't think of it as all that risky.
I mean, I was so excited
about what we were doing,
it's true I could have gone bankrupt,
but you know, I had a set of skills
that were highly employable,
and in fact my parents were still willing
to let me go back to Harvard
and finish my education
if I wanted to.
- You've always got a job with me, Bill.
(laughing)
- And the thing that was
scary to me wasn't quitting
and starting the company,
it was when I started hiring my friends
and they expected to be paid.
(audience laughs)
And then we had customers
who went bankrupt,
customers who I'd counted
on to come through,
and so then I got this
incredibly conservative approach
that I wanted to have
enough money in the bank
to pay a year's worth of payroll,
even if we didn't get
any payments coming in.
And I'm almost true to
that the whole time,
we have about 10 billion now,
which is pretty much
enough for the next year.
(audience laughs)
Anyway, you know, I, if you're
going to start a company
it takes so much energy
that it better overcome
your feeling of risk.
I don't think that you necessarily,
if you're going to start a company,
should do it at the start of your career,
I think there's a lot to be said
for working for a company,
learning how they do things,
if you're young, it's
hard to go lease premises,
they made that hard for me,
you couldn't rent a car when you were
under 25 at the time,
so I was always taking taxis
to go see customers.
(audience laughs)
And the people would say,
we're going to have a
discussion in the bar,
well I couldn't go to the bar.
(audience laughing)
(audience applauds)
But you know, that's fun
because I'll tell you,
when people are first skeptical,
and they go this kid
doesn't know anything,
then when you show them you've
really got a good product
and you know something,
they actually tend to go overboard
and they think "Whoa, they know a lot!
"Let's really do an incredible
amount with these people."
So our youth, at least in this country,
was a huge asset for us
once we reached a certain threshold.
It is hard, it's hard
to hire older people,
because they'll be a
little bit conservative
about whether they should
come and take the risk.
And it took three or four
years before we could go out
into the normal sort of employment pool.
But those problems come
with starting the firm.
You better think of those as part
of the pleasure, part of the challenge
that is part of the excitement.
- And what do you think
the biggest difference
between doing a play and doing,
I mean it's a cliched question
but I'd be interested to know your answer.
- I think a part of what Viola just said,
is that you get to dig deeper
and you get another day.
And you get the energy.
You do a movie, and it's 200
people that are used to it,
and they don't care, and
everybody's doing their job
and it comes in a theater somewhere,
and you're picking your
nose at home somewhere,
clipping your nails, there's no energy.
When I was on Broadway five
years ago, Julius Caesar,
I made a decision to sign
autographs every night
I don't know what I did, it
ain't happening this time!
(laughing)
(audience applauds)
Only, as I rub my knees,
only because my knees are bad.
It's harder for me to stand.
But--
- And why did you decide to do that?
- Well, you know, I
wanted to say thank you.
It was my way of saying thank you.
And the first night, it was
like, 5000 people out there
so okay, wait a minute,
everybody who has playbills from our show.
(laughter)
Yeah, because it was like,
people were just wandering up the block.
I'm like wait a minute, I forgot I'm on
you know, 42nd street and Times Square.
I said, wait a minute.
(audience laughing)
But honestly.
- You were signing for weeks.
- The energy.
I was out there hour and a
half, every night, every show.
- [Ann] Wow.
- But the energy you got back,
the stories, the five little old ladies
who just drove in from Detroit,
and I'm like well what
you all doing tonight?
They said "we getting
back in the car, baby,
"we got to go back tonight."
And you know, little old 84 year old lady
was like, "baby if I was
three years younger."
(audience laughing)
(audience applauds)
Oh, true story!
True story.
Then we had,
and I say this also,
because I hope it happens with this play,
we had some high schools come,
we had one school from
somewhere, I forgot where
and they were doing Julius Caesar.
And some young kid was
like "well, you know,
"my Brutus is a bit different."
(audience laughs)
"He's more the classic, stoic."
But it was great to engage,
and exchange with these young people,
there was an energy.
I got more from it than I gave
to the people that I signed for.
That's, you know, you don't get that,
you know the odd thing
about success in film
is that budgets get bigger,
you make more money,
but they become more formulaic.
So you don't get the opportunity.
So I, God willing, if I
stay around long enough,
this is what I'm going to be doing.
- One of the things that
people talk a lot about is,
what gets someone to
become an entrepreneur?
I mean I, it's just a
fascinating mindset, right?
You really have to be slightly delusional
to be an entrepreneur,
because you have to suspend disbelief.
Or you have to believe about your own idea
and have deep passion to go pursue it.
So in some sense, quite honestly,
before I even advise, I
take a lot of inspiration
from what you're doing.
It takes a lot of guts.
It takes a lot of energy
to be an entrepreneur.
And I think that
therein lies, I think,
your secret to success.
Which is your ability to overcome
every constraint and every obstacle.
And do it with the boldness,
and the risk-on nature of it.
I think it's fantastic.
If anything I would say,
especially for entrepreneurs,
is, you got to sustain
that sense of energy
over a long period of time
because you all know, and
you are grounded in it.
The mortality rate is super high.
And that means you will
be thrown curveballs
day in and day out,
and you have to be able to overcome that.
And so being a source of
energy in your small team,
especially if you're a CEO of a startup,
I like to sort of absolve them a lot,
because you can't have a bad day.
You're all the time.
You know you get up in the morning,
you're calling in the afternoon,
you're talking to your
investors in the evening,
you're, ya know, hiring,
and that constant sense of energy
and passion for what you're doing
is what I think it takes,
and to never give up,
which is what makes you who you are
in terms of the core makeup.
And I think that for me, I am
personally inspired by that
and I think that even
from a Microsoft culture,
that's what really my dream is.
My dream is not that, okay, we have
you know, a large organization,
my hope is that every
team inside of Microsoft
feels both that sense of energy
and empowerment and goes about it.
- Do you have moments of repose,
moments of just, just take
it in and sit quietly?
- No.
(audience laughs)
You know, I got to, I have
to do a lot of plane flights,
and I, oh, I'm a handful.
(audience laughs)
I don't know, I haven't
made it in the tabloids
as the bloke who's started
the riots and stuff on the planes, yet.
But I guarantee you it will happen.
You know, you can't hang
your arm out the window,
you can't stop and have a pee
and look at the wildlife,
you know, you're stuck in this thing
for like sometimes 14 hours in a leg,
you know what, going to America
is a 14 hour stint, mate,
and it's shocking awful to sit there
and all the, you know, you can't,
I like a good movie.
But not five of them in a row.
(audience laughs)
It's like, and you know I don't read much,
you know, I'm just.
- You don't read?
How come you don't read?
- Well, I do read, but not you know,
not for 14 hours.
(audience laughs)
You know, a SurfMax
takes a good 20 minutes.
(audience laughs)
♫ To all the ladies in the
place with style and grace
♫ Allow me to lace these
lyrical douches in your bushes
♫ Who rock grooves and make
moves with all the mommies
♫ The back of the club, sippin' Moet
♫ is where you'll find me
♫ The back of the club, mackin'
hoes, my crew's behind me
♫ Mad question askin', blunt
passin', music blastin'
To me, I like the live stuff
better than the stuff on the album
because the stuff on the
album seems more relaxed.
And I think you got to
have a certain tone,
know what I'm saying, like
maybe don't get too excited,
just chill, let it flow,
but when you're on stage,
sweat pouring down,
I'm a big one, too, sweat be drenching.
I just be representing,
know what I'm saying,
just doing my thing.
♫ Now they heard you blowin up like nitro
♫ and they want to stick the knife
♫ through your windpipe slow
- Do you run out of energy,
emotionally or physically?
- This is him not sleeping.
- This is me on no sleep now.
I don't.
I can't express how
happy of a person I am,
I can't express how inspiring
and, I guess you could say, motivating
my life and the people around me are.
- You know, things work in the moment,
and then can die off,
and then things can not work in one moment
and then come to life,
and if you have any wisdom whatsoever
you know to follow wherever
there is great energy.
And that's what I followed
with Denis when we did Enemy,
I went, this guy has great energy.
We vibe on each other, and
this, I got to go with this.
Like, I don't know what
this movie's about,
but I know this energy.
And I know this energy
is success somewhere.
Creative success.
And that's first and foremost to me.
And that's what I follow now.
And that energy drives a movie.
When you watch as an
audience, it's infectious
when you see that on a screen,
and I see it all the time with people,
you're infected by that energy.
And that's what we want.
- We average about 200,
about 250 to 275 concerts per year,
and sometimes that mean you
might do two in one day.
I'm 69, I'll be 70 on September the 16th
if I live that long.
And I find the energy meeting
people like yourselves.
I enjoy people.
I love to play, see people happy.
I love to see them dance and
see them enjoy themselves,
that's energy for me.
And it's educational.
I get a chance to learn
how to say merci beaucoup.
(laughs)
I don't speak French, but Lucille does.
Music is a universal language,
and I believe that because
it's been many times
I've heard great musicians,
like Django Reinhardt I love,
you never hear him speak English,
but he speaks it with his guitar.
So I think music is a universal language
that we can, I believe,
communicate with anyone.
- I think of energy, in its,
and anyone listening to this
it's really important,
when you start, the
way I did, with United,
at 43, 44 years of age,
you see the energy, the
players see the energy
they see it bouncing out of you.
but when you get to the 60s,
they still expect to see it.
So I have to work at
myself in terms of energy.
The hours I've slept,
because when I was a young manager,
four or five hours, no problem.
When I got to that, to my 60s,
I needed six or seven hours.
So you go to bed earlier,
you work at your diet better,
Saturday nights were out,
after the game went home,
you know, I never, very very seldom
go out on a Saturday night.
So that, I had to examine
myself as a manager
because people want to see the energy.
It's a very important
aspect of it, you know.
- Hands up, hands up
I always envisioned myself being a rapper
and being in the game and having success,
but you never know what
it really feels like
or how you're going to
be when you're there.
(audience cheering)
Hands up!
♫ And they say all I rap
about is bitches and champagne
♫ You would too if every
night you seen the same thing
The name Wiz comes from
me being the youngest dude
in my age group of people
that I hung out with.
They would call me a young wiz,
you know, like I was wise beyond my years,
and the Khalifa is Arabic,
it means successor,
leader, shining light, and my
granddad gave me that name.
He's actually Muslim, so you know,
he's just seeing my path
and what I was doing
and how hard I was working,
and he gave me that name, and
I just put the two together.
(rapping)
Of course, I do rap music
and I'm a hip hop artist,
but as an individual,
as a personality and what
I give to the people,
I see myself as like,
the lead singer of a band
or something. (laughs)
You know, when I go out
there, I'm a real performer.
It's all about the vibe and the feeling,
you got to be balanced, and it's like,
nothing that I have to put on,
I really feel, you know, that energetic
and that happy to be in front of the kids.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know, what did you think?
Did you get your energy raised
from watching this video?
What was the most important
lesson that you learned
that you want to apply to your life
or your business immediately,
what's the first action step
that you're going to take to apply it,
leave it in the comments below,
super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick shout-out
to BestYouPRO, thank you so much
for picking up a copy of
my book "Your One Word"
and taking that awesome picture
on Twitter and posting it,
I really really really
really appreciate it.
Thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you, I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is, much love,
I'll see you soon.